يعني هنا مقبره الحي النمساوي حيث عاثت
اليات الاحتلال خرابا وفسادا ودمارا في
هذه المقبره حيث المقابر كما تشاهدون في
الصوره تم نبشه من قبل اليات الاحتلال
وجنود الاحتلال وهنا تدمير واسي لحق بهذه
المقبره نتيجه عبث اليات الاحتلال اضافه
الى عمليات قصف قامت بها طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه لهذه المقبره قبل الدخول
الفعلي من قبل اليه الاحتلال الى هذه
المقبره التي تقع في الاجزاء الغربيه
لمحافظه خانيونس اضافه الى ان هذه المقبره
تقع بجوار المستشفى الميداني الاردني كما
تشاهدون في الصوره ما لا يبعد المستشفى
الميدان الاردني عن هذه المقبره وعن تواجد
الاليات في هذه المنطقه سوى امتار قليله
وكان هناك غطاء ناري كثيف من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال وكذلك ان طائرات
الاحتلال قامت بشن غارات عنيفه جدا قبل
دخول ووصول اليه الاحتلال الى هذا المكان
هنا في هذه المقبره تم نبش عدد كبير من
مقابر
الموتى
وكذلك كما نشاهد في الصوره هنا جثامين
شهداء على ما يبدو
تم دفنهم في اوقات قريبه جدا كما نشاهد في
الصوره لكن لم يتسنى لنا الحصول على تاريخ
معين لكن كما نشاهد في الصوره كما هو واضح
بان دفن هؤلاء الشهداء كان في وقت قريب
جدا تم نبش هذه المقابر انا بالصدفه
للسمار من هنا جاي على شغلي لا بقولوا
بفحر في المقابر قبر ابويا مفحار وقبر
عمام وقول على ايش محرين القبور هدول ناس
ميته لها سنين ميته ايش دخل الناس هذه جسس
هذا للكلاب هلقيت كليت تمش فيهم هذول طب
هذا مش حرام هذا هنا جثمان احد
الاطفال الحاله والوضع صعب جدا من خلال
غارات ن وتها طائرات الاحتلال بشكل كثيف
وعنيف
وهذا احدث حاله من الفزع لدى المواطنين
خاصه القاطنين بالقرب من هذا المكان ومن
هذه المقبره الواقعه في الاجزاء الغربيه
لمحافظه خان يونس اذا الاموات هم في
الكبور مش سالمين ماخذين جته اليهود معهم
بفكروا في جنود ويهود ميتين هنا حسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل على كان السبب يا اخو
اطلع عش 200 ذا 200 شيليهم من القبور طلع
هم برا هي الضمار تفرج حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل على اسرائيل وعلى الب شركه ايضا في
المنازل المجاوره هناك كما تشاهدون في
اقصى هذه الصوره تعرضت هذه المنازل لغارات
عنيفه وكذلك بعض المصانع على ما يبدو في
محيط هذه المقبره نتيجه هذا القصف العنيف
والكبير الذي قامت به طائرات الاحتلال اذا
عدوان جديد هذه المره باستهداف المقابر في
منطقه خان يونس تحديدا في الحي
النمساوي مع كل يوم يتكشف لنا اثار جديده
لعدوان الاحتلال على قطاع غزه لقناه
الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس جنوب
قطاع غزه